[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis super content d'être là ce soir
émission spéciale oui je vous trouve
rayonnante et vous animez superman
commission spéciale ironique scotia
sur les animaux c'est ça et je suis
rassuré parce que pour l'instant il n'y
a pas de chien actuellement sur le
plateau et je vous dis ça parce que j'ai
regardé quelques émissions et parfois ça
se passe pas trop comme prévu je dirais
même que c'est carrément le bordel des
fois comme sur ce plateau new yorkais
avec ce chien un peu pressés de se
soulager
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au moins ça va il l'a fait une fois ça
peut pas dire page d'accueil
j'ai pensé pour cette journaliste qui a
clairement été prise pour un lampadaire
forteresse vénère
je comprends pas trop ce qui est dit
mais je crois que c'est un peu binaire 1
et quand c'est pas pour pisser nos potes
les chiens se soulager autrement
[Applaudissements]
ça marche pas
alors on l'a vu ça soulage pas mal sur
les plateaux télé mais parfois c'est un
peu plus relou comme ce chien qui a
voulu intervenir en plein direct
des process
apparemment et court toujours ans j'ai
vu passer devant les studios tout à
l'heure même chaîne même problème
visiblement ce chien de carrément
prendre le contrôle du plateau
ça va quoi
ni kaboré en france aussi on aime
recevoir nos amis les chiens en direct
sur les plateaux de télé
voilà exactement il est très calme ouais
trek et enfin pas vraiment
[Musique]
très nerveux
est en cours on a tous déjà tenté
l'excusent turiddu désolé mon chien a
mangé mon devoir est basse est
journaliste à prouver que ça pouvait
vraiment arrivé
une image un peu plus récent de mai déjà
culte un coup de gueule d'une rare
violence âmes sensibles s'abstenir
donald regarde la réalité
qui a fait ça
c'est toi
c'est toi je sais que c'est lui donc
arrête de faire genre c'est pas toi à
vous dépêcher et je vais te pardonne et
se moquent de moi
la main dans le sac la bombe on va pas
se mentir c'est un bon solitude pour
guillaume mais franchement ça va à côté
de ce présentateur météo américain qui a
tout tenté pour remplacer une
sur
[Applaudissements]
tout
alors delphine vous l'avez dit vous le
savez tous les mercredis dans tpm paix
avec son lot je reviens sur les dark à
des interviews politiques et pour
l'occasion je me suis dit pourquoi pas
revenir sur les moments des chiens des
politiques ce soir on offre des cadeaux
pour les refuge canin et il y en a un
autre qui offrent souvent des cadeaux
c'est michel drucker avant de te quitter
je les cadeaux ça c'est pour toi merci
beaucoup ça c'est pour toi merci ça va
c'est des livres mais quand il avait
reçu président jacques chirac qui
s'était un peu chauffé sur le cadeau
d'anniversaire de ses produits merci
infiniment
et j'ai un cadeau pour vous au
tout à fait mis les monsieur loyal et
d'ailleurs pour le choix du prénom
michel drucker était un peu trop
impliqué c'est l'année des oeufs vous
appellerez sait pas où elle vit ici et
lisez les doigts oui mais vous choisirez
way ambiance un peu plus strictes en
russie on a appris que poutine avait
toujours deux trois croquettes dans sa
poche sera d'état
et une véritable histoire d'amour en
irlande au président de la république
qui se balade toujours avec ses chiens
envira limite un prétendant de l'amour
est dans le pré lien
et d'ailleurs petite info politique le
président de la république qu'on vient
de voir mesure un toutou et demi de
savants
et on finit à domicile à l'elysée au
mémo le chien d'emmanuel macro est un
peu trop à l'aise sur le mobilier story
tard
sur la question
non
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]